It's called the
Hare Krishna movement.
A colorful group,
often seen dancing and
chanting in the streets.
What most Americans think
when they hear Hare Krishna is
peaceful people.
Nothing about
making someone disappear.
This is the case
that's probably
going to be with me
for the rest of my life.
There are two worlds.
The material world
and the spiritual world.
You have these young,
immature people suddenly
acquiring this absolute power
over other human beings.
Keith Ham wanted to
take over the movement.
Manipulative, power hungry.
He was the devil incarnate.
My father said
he's not a real guru
and my family was destroyed.
It's a whodunit.
Why did this guy get shot?
And he's connected to the Krishnas
in West Virginia.
I promised that I would
stay for 6 months
and didn't get out for 11 years.
Just like the mob.
You can't have a snitch.
You didn't go
against Keith Ham.
If you did...
we didn't hear from you again.